[Music]
hey you guys it's me again back with yet
another book review
just like my last few um i've been doing
some stuff that just kind of came up on
kindle unlimited so i'm just kind of
scrolling through there and looking for
highly rated stuff or stuff people have
recommended to me and stuff like that so
the one that i read this week man this
was a good one and i had actually never
heard of this author um i think she's
written uh several books i think six
seven eight something like that kind of
all set around the seattle area where
she lives although i think she's
originally from toronto her name is
jennifer hillier
and this book is called
jar of hearts now i guess there was a
song called that because she does kind
of like quote it in there so that's
where she got the title from but i think
one of the things that attracted me to
this book in particular because i was
scrolling through all the stuff on
kindle unlimited and this one the cover
is really cool like actually the couple
versions of the cover are really cool
and this one was like very very very
highly rated i don't even think i didn't
read all the good breeds reviews because
there's a [ __ ] ton but it really did
seem that all of them pretty much were
in the four and a half to five star
range and that's probably where i would
put this one as well because
this book
it's funny because i started reading it
and i was just kind of like i'll just
you know read for half an hour an hour
until i go and do something else on on
new year's day i started it and uh i
ended up reading the whole entire book
in one city because it was pretty long
and i couldn't like because i couldn't
stop i was just kind of like it was
really
it was one of those really like
compulsive reads where it's just kind of
like oh she was like you don't even want
to like get up and go to the bathroom
and stuff like that so it's like it's
really really good
so
it's a thriller
um apparently it was kind of it got a
lot of buzz i think when it first came
out i think it came out back in summer
of 2018
and it won like a couple of awards the
following year but i remember i mean i
don't remember this actually but i
remember like a lot of people talking
about it like at the time that it came
out and i just didn't get around to it i
really like i do like thrillers but i
tend to
i tend to go more toward like pure
horror first because some thrillers i
like a lot of thrillers like i said but
a lot of thrillers tend to
toward kind of like more of a i don't
really mean mean to sound this
this to sound derogatory but it does
sound
they kind of go a little bit more in
like the lifetime movie direction
because i guess they know like a lot of
you know a lot they have a lot of female
readers that read that genre so they do
kind of tend to go that way this one uh
does not really have anything like that
honestly this one it's pretty gruesome
and i'm gonna say right here if you're
bothered by um sort of fairly graphic
descriptions of rape uh there are a
couple of those in here murders of
children
rape murder and dismemberment of women
one attempted rape that was also
incestuous and also the main character
is in love with someone who turns who
turned out to be a serial killer and so
there's kind of like a bunch of
really [ __ ] up relationships going on
in this but that was actually one of the
reasons i loved it the main character in
this whose name is georgina or geo for
short she's a great character because
she's really complex and you really do
kind of like get inside her head this
isn't from first person it basically
switches back and forth it's mostly from
her point of view but it also um goes
back and forth to
the point of view of one of the cops
who's investigating it whose name is
kaiser and he's actually a childhood
friend of hers like they used to be
besties back in the day so there's kind
of that whole complicating issue as well
but she's such a great character because
i don't say she's unlikable she's not
but
you still it's this is why this is such
a great book you still kind of feel bad
for her you
you feel like a lot of emotions for her
even though
she did some really really shitty things
and made some really really terrible
stupid decisions which kind of like
ruined her whole life you know so so i'm
going to say so the characterization in
this was just
was amazing especially of her character
she's just a really you really just want
to keep reading about her because she's
just like a fascinating
person and like her psychology is really
fascinating
so what we have now this is another book
i didn't know all i knew was it was a
thriller and it was kind of like serial
killer adjacent and i was just kind of
like okay whatever and it had like a
whole bunch of really good reviews so i
said okay well that's the next one i'm
gonna read
so i didn't really even read the
description and i will recommend as i
usually do whether it's books movies
anything i like reading books watching
movies
not knowing or knowing as little as
possible about them like maybe just the
genre or oh it's a monster movie or
whatever um and then i just kind of let
it take me on a journey uh however
obviously since i'm gonna be talking
about it i am gonna i'm not gonna spoil
the end or anything like that or any of
the big twists and turns but
in describing how the plot goes um it
might spoil some things along the way so
if you want to read this book and don't
want to know anything about it obviously
what the [ __ ] are you doing watching
this video but i'm just warning you
ahead of time as i said i'm not going to
spoil the ending but
you know i will like mention some stuff
from the plot so if you don't want to
know anything about it then go read it
you can read it for free if you have
kindle unlimited or obviously you can
buy the paperback or get the audiobook
or whatever so as i said this seemed
like it was a really popular read
right around when it came out like a
very popular summer read i guess for
for [ __ ] up people like me
who like like really horror like true
crime type [ __ ] but yeah this is kind of
what everybody was reading uh back in
the summer of 2018. so as i said our
main character is a woman named georgina
shaw
now at the very beginning you know
that she did something kind of bad
because pretty much from like in the
first scene i believe
is her
testifying at a trial
now the trial is for a dude named calvin
james
who is a serial killer
you find out pretty soon in the story
that calvin and georgina were boyfriend
and girlfriend back in high school days
although she was much younger than him
she was i believe 16 when she met him he
was 21.
so there was that so she was like going
out with the older guy as i said this is
set around the seattle washington uh
type area and some of it it it basically
it just jumps back and forth from like
high school days to
uh you know kind of telling you what
happened back then to
modern day and it kind of jumps around
in time a lot you know a little bit but
not really all that much
so uh so yeah so she's testifying at the
trial
and they establish almost immediately
that
she must have done something to help him
or
something like that because she has she
got a plea deal so she's actually going
to be in prison for five years uh even
though she's testifying uh to get him
you know put in prison for life for
being a serial killer and he's up for
four murders now one of these murders
the first one is the one that you're
assuming that she was
involved in in some way as the story
goes on you don't really find out
to what extent she was involved in the
murder
um you know that's something that's sort
of slowly revealed and later on in the
story uh it actually does do like an
extended for of exactly what happened
but uh so she kind of keeps it close to
the vest so she's um you know she's at
the trial she does her deal and then uh
she goes back and they put her in jail
because that's what the plea deal was
and before she goes though like when
she's in the in the courtroom the serial
killer calvin who was her ex-boyfriend
now she hasn't seen him for many years
um he slips her a note and all the note
says is you're welcome
so
like i said pretty much from early on in
the story you know that she was involved
somehow and then perhaps he's implying
that he's taking the fall for her or
something of that nature like i said
it's
slowly revealed as the story goes on
so what ends up happening so georgina
even though she was maybe maybe not she
had this boyfriend in high school who
turned out to be a serial killer later
on he's actually like killed several
women
and uh raped and killed several women in
the meantime like since she was you know
since they parted company
when uh you know many years ago
so in the meantime though uh she has
become very very successful and she
knows that by giving this plea deal and
going to prison for five years
and be being associated publicly with
this serial killer that essentially her
life before which was idyllic like a
fantasy lifestyle is over
uh she had worked her way up in a
pharmaceuticals company and was now like
the vice president or something
and she was actually engaged to be
married to the guy that ran the company
this fabulously wealthy guy like she had
like a really nice car she had all of
this stuff you know when she was quite
young i think she's only 30 years old so
she was in all the business world she
was very like a big deal like how she's
so high up in this company and being so
young and being a woman and all this
other kind of stuff so she is like of
kind of a public face of this company so
when it comes out
that uh that she was involved in the
serial killer because what ended up
happening was that the first crime that
was committed uh the first
girl that was raped and murdered was her
best friend in high school because of
her involvement they didn't find the
girl's body for like 14 years so that's
why georgina has been able to build this
whole entire
life um because
you know they the body wasn't found
until much later and then you know they
found out what her involvement was and
then she ends up getting arrested so
after the trial there's kind of an
extended this book is actually divided
into five sections which are kind of
like different stages of grief they're
called that
so um so that's kind of the first part
and then the second part is actually her
doing her time in prison that's actually
a really good uh section too because
you're kind of seeing like all the
sort of [ __ ] she puts like all the abuse
she puts up with like what it's like in
there and then she kind of ends up
you know making friends with
sort of like a higher up like higher
ranking prisoner that's very powerful
and has a lot of friends on the outside
so she kind of gets in with that because
she was such a high-powered like
business executive you know she can do
financial [ __ ] for people and everything
so she like starts doing favors so then
after five years she gets out
of prison and then has to go back to her
hometown and she's going back to live
with her dad because obviously her uh
you know fiance abandoned her uh all her
money is pretty much gone uh she can't
really get a job uh anymore because
everybody knows who she is she's like
notorious
and so uh so she's kind of [ __ ] so she
goes back and lives in her childhood
home in her dad's house and then you
know like the dad's house is getting
vandalized and all this other stuff
because like i said everybody knows who
she is and she has like a really bad
reputation now because you know she was
involved with this serial killer even
though it happened when she was a
teenager and even though
he was obviously very controlling and
abusive
but
she did
even though she was only 16 when she did
the dumb [ __ ] that she did it was still
pretty like some pretty dumb [ __ ] and
she could have like
fixed it at any point and she really
kind of hurt a lot of people but that's
sort of like the point of the book is
that you do sympathize with her because
she was just like a dumb teenager and
you could see yourself getting into that
situation
but
her
basically
you know just kind of compounding the
error like as it went on pretty much
like i said it's essentially like ruined
her whole entire life
and so the book is really good at
showing that how just this one stupid
decision that you made or this one
person that you knew even when you were
a teenager like you know you just keep
if you just keep lying and like
compounding your error and [ __ ] like
that it just makes your life spiral out
of control in like horrible ways that
probably you didn't foresee so so that
was kind of like thing too so when she
gets out
um you know it's kind of like this big
you know [ __ ] nightmare she can't
find a job or anything and her dad's
kind of getting his house [ __ ] with
and everything because she's there and
you know all the people that she used to
know in the town are just like shunning
her now and it turns out that her best
friend from high school uh
you know because her the girl that got
killed back in high school and it was
named angela and she was kind of like
the the queen bee type girl and her and
georgina hung out and then they hung out
with this other guy named kaiser and
kaiser was in love with georgina like
back in the day but georgina kind of
like friend zoned him and was going out
with calvin who became a serial killer
later on and it was like this horrible
[ __ ] up abusive situation that she was
in
but kaiser was pretty cool about it um
he did go a little nice guy but not
really
so kaiser now that everyone's grown up
kaiser is now a cop and he's actually
the one that investigated he's the one
that helped like did the uh
investigation like when they found
angela's body finally after 14 years and
stuff so
obviously he's still kind of carrying a
torch for georgina and now that it's
this much
this many years later and he knows that
georgina was involved in angela's murder
somehow although he's not quite sure
what the extent of her involvement was
so his uh feelings about her are very
conflicted now into this situation it
appears uh calvin actually escapes from
prison uh he was on he wasn't on death
row but he had was serving like multiple
life sentences so he actually escapes
from prison and then another series of
murders starts up
that maybe suggests that calvin is
either killing again or
there's somebody doing a copycat thing
or
calvin is trying to get georgina's
attention because he knows that she's
out of prison now too
but the mo of the crimes is sort of like
his ones but sort of different
so that's kind of how the rest of the
book goes where
it's this new series of murders this new
investigation
and georgina
feeling like she's being targeted by
calvin because you know he's presumably
killing again or trying to get her
attention uh by doing these particular
things like he'll kill he starts killing
like a series of women and children like
little kids like two three four years
old and he like leaves messages like on
their bodies and they're ostensibly for
her
so that's kind of where it goes so it's
so like i said it goes back and forth
between her
and kaiser who's the cop that's
investigating it who's got his own
[ __ ] problems going on too like he's
having an affair and well he's not
married but his the woman he's having
affair with is married and also they
work together so he hasn't you know he
he's doing a lot better than georgina
but
he's kind of like [ __ ] up dude
everyone in this is kind of [ __ ] up
but
this was
i mean this was one of those books where
like i said i sat down to read it and
literally i was just gonna be like oh
okay well i'll just get i'll start this
like i'll just read a chapter or two and
i ended up reading the whole entire book
you know what i mean uh on new year's
day because i was like well it's new
year's day it's kind of a holiday and
then i just kept reading and reading
rain because i couldn't stop and man it
is so good like the characterization is
so good i didn't really see it's like
this story has so many like twists and
turns
and most of them i did not see coming
one of them i did but i didn't see it
coming until
maybe like a
when you were kind of supposed to see it
coming i guess so you know what i mean
uh i didn't really call it like super
early in the story but it just goes in
all of these ways that you're not really
expecting it to go and it's great i mean
it's just and now like i said it's it's
a thriller but
it definitely has
some pretty
grisly some pretty gruesome [ __ ] so as i
said if you're really bothered by
fairly graphic descriptions of rapes and
stuff like that um this might not be the
book for you it's not gory but you know
stuff is described like pretty you know
pretty straightforwardly
um there's several rapes in this like i
said and there's uh one attempted rape
which as i mentioned is also incestuous
and it's you know babies are killed like
two three four-year-old kids are killed
women are killed and caught up so
you know uh if that bothers you then
maybe this isn't because this is a
definitely like more on the graphic
grizzly end some more on the horror end
of thriller rather than the kind of just
like
regular
you know sexy time kind of thriller this
is not everybody in this is
i don't want to say everyone in this is
terrible
but
everyone in this is very they have
terrible aspects to their character like
pretty much everybody so
all the characters were really really
good because they were all really
complex not necessarily likable like a
lot of them like i said did really
terrible awful things
but
you could still kind of
you still saw the humanity in all of
them
you know i mean which was kind of great
i mean even the guy that was the serial
killer calvin uh he was obviously like a
horrible horrible person
but
you still
there was still like a glimmer of
humanity there you didn't feel sad for
him or you didn't like you weren't
sympathetic toward him or anything like
that but you could see that he was still
like a human being and he's and he
seemed
i guess because he was seemed kind of
aware that what he was doing was really
bad um but he seemed like he couldn't
really stop himself
so but like i said it's he's not
portrayed sympathetically by any stretch
of the imagination but
everybody in this has
you know really shitty things about
their character but
everybody's kind of like realistically
portrayed you know what i mean so i
think that's what i really liked about
it was like the characterization and i
really loved like all the twists and
turns that the story took and
i you know the outcome of it i didn't
really see where it was going you know
what i mean which i thought was like
really really cool but
it's really one of those books i know
it's like kind of a cliche to say oh i
couldn't put it down it's like but i
literally could not i mean i was reading
the ebook so like off my computer screen
so it's not like i'm putting it down
like a literal book but i literally like
i couldn't like pull my face away from
the screen because i was just kind of
like okay i'll just gonna read one more
chapter no now what's happening you know
what i mean but it's just like really
good i loved all the character
interactions just so so good so i can
see why uh this got
pretty much overwhelmingly awesome
reviews because
this is one of the most compulsively
readable
books i think i've read in a very long
time that i just kind of sat and read
the whole
however many pages with 300 400 pages it
was and i just sat there and read the
whole [ __ ] thing like in one sitting
without like without even hardly getting
up but that's how that's how good it was
so
as i said um if you're really into
thrillers that are more on the serial
killer graphic sort of end and if you
don't mind
um sort of graphic depictions of rape
child murder dismemberment and also like
some really [ __ ] up
relationship dynamics in the sense that
of you know a teenage girl being
essentially like in love with the serial
killer and still kind of being in love
with them even after she found out what
he did uh so
if that's gonna bother you then probably
give skip this one but if it's not going
to bother you if that sounds like
something that's up your alley then this
is a really really good really good book
i mean i had a really good time with
this one uh so yeah that will do it for
this tomes of terror i will see you guys
on the next one bye